police start searching for a motive
behind a deadly shooting rampage in
Louisiana law enforcement say 21 year
old Dakota Theriot killed five people
Saturday including his parents and a 20
year old woman believed to be his
girlfriend they say he then drove more
than 1,100 miles to Virginia where he
was arrested
Harold Barnett is in Warsaw Virginia
outside the jail where tario is being
held
Erol good morning good morning tario is
here at the Northern Neck Regional Jail
being held on no bond now he faces an
extradition hearing set for Friday that
would have him sent back to Louisiana
where he faces five counts of murder for
allegedly killing his own parents a
young woman and her family as well
there's infinite I never would have
thought it would mean my children Rhonda
champagnes world was ripped apart over
the weekend police say 21 year old
Dakota tario shot and killed two of her
children 20-year old summer earnest and
17 year-old Tanner earnest
along with their father 43 year old bill
earnest junior police say tario was
living with the Earnest family for the
last few weeks inside this mobile home
in Livingston Parish investigators say
after shooting the earnest family tario
then went to his family's mobile home
nearby where he opened fire on his
parents Keith and Elisabeth tario both
died but not before the father gave
police a vital clue we was able to get a
dying declaration from him only enough
information to let us know that it was
his son that committed this act
police say tario then drove to Richmond
County Virginia where his grandmother
lives but she was gone having already
checked into a hotel after hearing about
the shootings
she asked Richmond Sheriff's to check on
her home and officers were there when
tario pulled up had a pistol in his hand
he had it out of the window officers
engaged him tario dropped the gun and
was taken into custody
relatives of the earnest family are glad
he was arrested but say it doesn't fill
the giant void he left them
my niece and my nephew it'll never be
happy it'll never be the same and your
heart just goes out to everyone impacted
by this interestingly enough the sheriff
Stan Louisiana said that there were no
red flags in regards to tario before
this shooting authorities also say he
was asked to leave the earnest home and
told not to come back for the earnest
family the next step will be
particularly painful as they planned
funerals for not just one but four three
beloved family members unimaginable
Errol thank you